wow Fox News and Dominion voting systems
have settled Dominion's
1.6 billion dollar defamation suit
against Fox News they have settled it at
787 million dollars just as the trial
was starting this will require and did
require Fox News in writing to concede
that they got some things wrong AKA lied
but it will not require them to make
on-air apologies and we're going to talk
about that now as we talked about
yesterday and the news yesterday was
there is not going to be a settlement
within minutes of that episode going
live they reached a settlement what we
talked about yesterday was the to some
degree lose-lose aspect to this for Fox
News if you settle it you're admitting
wrongdoing whether you admit wrongdoing
in writing or not it's understood that
you're not fighting for what you believe
to be true to the end of the tri you're
settling you're saying yeah okay fine
we'll pay we'll pay because we did the
thing at least to some degree that we
are accused of doing and of course they
can try to wash it by saying it's not
that we believe we did anything wrong
but it became clear that they were going
to drag this out for political reasons
we're the victims okay fine but you're
saying we're gonna pay
if you refuse
and you go into a four or even six week
trial you see six weeks of headlines
including potentially more Discovery
elements texts phone calls who knows
what could come out and it could be even
more damaging potentially so as deadline
reports Fox News agrees to pay 787
million dollars to settle the Dominion
false election claims case fox has
admitted to telling lies said the voting
systems CEO the Delaware Superior Court
Judge Eric Davis overseeing the case
made an announcement that quote the
parties have resolved their case
offering no additional details news of
the subtle settlement was strategically
made public right before Wall Street
ceased trading for the day it is going
to be 787 million dollars 787 and a half
million in fact uh fox has admitted to
telling lies about Dominion that caused
enormous damage to my company our
employees and the customers we serve
said Dominion CEO John polos nothing can
make up for that Fox News is not
required to air an apology or retraction
however Fox was quick to address the
settlement in crafted language that
softly walks back the claims made by
hosts and guests that the 2020 election
was stolen from Donald Trump there's a
couple different aspects to this that I
think are very very important to talk
about one of them is that we have to
distinguish Free Speech claims from
defamation
this is not about Free Speech this is
about a responsibility for a public
platform the size of Fox News
not to defame others and when we talk
about defamation we're talking about
false claims damaging to one's
reputation were it true that Dominion
participated in rigging the election to
steal it from trump it would be damaging
to their reputation but it would be
accurate and therefore it would not be
defamation and so the Crux of this is
inextricably interwoven with the lies
told about the 2020 election Trump
didn't win Biden did and whatever story
you had about uh cured ballots or
sauteed ballots or grilled ballots and
stuff to you know a double double
stuffed crust ballots or whatever or it
was dominion and smartmatic that rigged
it or whatever it's all part of a bigger
lie now we have video here of lawyers
for Dominion
uh who are taking the perspective that
lies have consequences and that is true
whatever you think about 800 million
dollars nearly is that the right amount
lies have consequences is the
perspective that they are taking today's
settlement
of
787 million five hundred thousand
dollars represents vindication
and accountability lies have
consequences
the truth does not know red or blue
today I want to also be really clear
that this is not going to take down Fox
News there is a smartmatic defamation
suit as well and that could get settled
for hundreds of millions as well it's
it's not going to take down Fox News
financially we then get to the question
is it going to take down Fox News in
other ways yesterday I told you that fox
has major negotiations coming up with
three major cable providers Fox unlike
most cable channels doesn't really
depend on Advertising so much as they
have negotiated fees per cable
subscriber I have a cable subscription I
don't watch Fox News but a couple bucks
I believe somewhere between two and four
dollars of my monthly payment goes to
Fox because that's the deal that fox has
negotiated so there's the question of
whether in in the under the black cloud
of this uh settlement and future
lawsuits that continue whether Fox is
going to be able to negotiate the same
sort of deal that may hurt them and then
secondly there's the question of wow now
that they've paid nearly 800 million to
settle a defamation claim in which they
lied to Their audience maybe they will
lose their audience but of course I
don't think that that's going to happen
the Fox News viewer actually sees Fox
News as the victim here by and large I
want to play a couple of interesting
clips for you here is um Fox Media
analyst Howard Kurtz appearing with Neil
Cavuto just moments after the
announcement of the settlement and uh
take a look at what he had to say this
had to do with the idea that Dominion
voting machines and former president
Trump and his allies made this case on
Fox and elsewhere where somehow stealing
votes from Donald Trump and flipping
them to Joe Biden that's obviously false
those were conspiracy theories but the
case would have revolved around uh you
know whether Fox had done due children's
whether it was Reckless whether it was
simply reporting as the network contends
on an extremely newsworthy matter argued
by the former then president of the
United States himself so whether the
amount of the settlement will leak often
it doesn't maybe that's part of the deal
but at this point that's what we know
okay so a couple different things one
reaction to that clip was wow look
that's Fox News admitting on Fox news
that the stuff that they said was
obviously untrue Kurtz really downplays
it significantly he said oh you know
there were there were some statements
made which were not true this was was
months and months of coverage on both
the news and opinion sides giving voice
to the wackiest of wacky you know Sydney
Powell and Mike pillow and all these
other people it was more than just ah
some things were said that weren't true
that being said Fox News is going to
minimize this incredibly and eventually
frame themselves as the victims I want
to show you an article that was
published about the settlement yesterday
it's fewer than 200 words long it
mentions that the judge praised Fox's
lawyers and it doesn't mention what the
settlement amount was the article is
called Fox news media Dominion voting
systems reach agreement over defamation
lawsuit Dominion filed a 1.6 billion
lawsuit against fox in 2021
Delaware Superior Court Judge Eric Davis
praised both parties for the handling of
their case quote I've been on the bench
since 2010 I think this is the best
lawyering I've had ever I would be proud
to be your judge in the future the
settlement came as a trial was scheduled
to launch this week with a jury selected
earlier in the day the lawsuit stemmed
from coverage of the post-2020
presidential election and it became
media fodder then president Trump and
his allies challenged Joe Biden's
Victory some of them including members
of his legal team made false and
unsubstantiated claims against Dominion
voting systems and are the subject of
separate defamation lawsuits done end of
story you scroll down it's just ads okay
that's the full story not Fox News has
admitted in writing that they signal
boosted those claims Fox News is going
to pay nearly 800 million dollars to get
this to go away none of that stuff is
included this is the summary the nice
tidy summary of This by Fox News so this
is the way that it ends with Dominion
advantage to Dominion of going this
route also includes that rather than a
drawn out trial potentially appeals and
then trying to collect the settlement
they presumably will have a much more
direct path to that 787 million dollars
interestingly just before the settlement
was announced Fox News lawyers through
Trump and allies under the bus I want to
talk about that next this is super
interesting
in the moments before it became known
that Fox News and Dominion voting
systems settled the Dominion defamation
suit wherein Fox News will pay Dominion
787.5 million dollars when it looked
like this was going to go to trial and
continue to trial towards the end
the lawyers representing Fox News
through Trump and his allies under the
bus and this is absolutely fantastic
Newsweek reports Fox News throws Trump
under the bus and reads Fox news's legal
defense appears to have taken on a new
strategy in the company's fight against
a defamation lawsuit by Dominion voting
systems for the Network's alleged lies
about the company during the 2020
election blaming Donald Trump
critical element to this uh which is a
quote from the article we will put up on
the screen quote the night before the
trial scheduled start attorneys for Fox
News filed documents imploring the judge
overseeing the case to allow them to
introduce evidence arguing the companies
allegedly defamatory claims against
Dominion voting machines were primarily
inspired by Trump's own rhetoric that
the election with dominions involvement
was specifically rigged against him this
is the similar idea that many of the
January 6th rioters tried to invoke as
their legal defense when their cases
were adjudicated it's Trump's fault
Trump told us to Riot Trump told us to
be here whatever and then Trump says I
said peacefully and you know that's
where the debate comes from it's a very
similar argument that Fox News lawyers
were going to make of course the case
ultimately ended up being settled now I
want to be really clear and honest with
you about what this is versus what it is
not this strategy from Fox News saying
trump it was Trump trump was leading
this whole thing this is not Fox News
finding a moral compass or anything of
the sort not even close this is what Fox
News always does we've seen so many
examples of it and and Alex Jones has
done it who's separate from Fox News and
so have many others of these right
Wingers the lawyers will try to come up
with whatever legal argument is best
when they need to do it in a court of
law it is totally separate from what
happens on the air
for example when lawyers argued in court
that Tucker Carlson is an Entertainer
he's not a news person he's an
Entertainer
he uses hyperbole he uses exaggeration
you can't hold him legally accountable
for the letter of everything he says it
might look like a news show but
fundamentally Tucker is an Entertainer
and it's not that he's lying it's that
he's using the stylistic tools of
Hyperbole and exaggeration but the zoom
out big picture takeaway here always is
that we have to remember that they want
to be seen as newsworthy and trustworthy
in terms of their Public Presentation
when it becomes legally too hot they
step back and say well that's an opinion
show and this is entertainment and
whatever else the case may be that's the
same here
when they were doing the rep the quote
reporting I I'm using language that
doesn't even make sense it wasn't
reporting when they were doing the
propaganda and lies around Trump
actually won and Dominion voting systems
was part of the rigging and all these
things they were doing it yes primarily
for Ratings but by presenting it as if
they really believe it whether they did
or didn't it's a mixed bag it seems that
Tucker and Laura Ingram and Hannity
didn't believe it but that Maria
Bartiromo did okay it does it doesn't
matter they were presenting it as news
and then now they want to say well
listen I mean we were just kind of
repeating the stuff Trump said it wasn't
so much that we believed it or that we
were trying to defame anybody end of the
line here is 787.5 million dollars
settlement agreed to by dominion and Fox
News Fox News will pay the smartmatic
defamation lawsuit isn't over and
continues after the break I want to dig
in specifically
to this little detail that Fox News will
not have to apologize on air for
defamatory election lies make sure
you're subscribed on the YouTube channel
youtube.com the davidpackman show quick
break right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show does depend on the
support of our podcast listeners our
YouTube viewers people who listen on the
radio or see a tick tock clip here and
there we primarily fund our program
through the membership program you can
learn about that at joinpakman.com all
right we already talked about the Fox
News defamation suit is not going to
conclude with a with a trial verdict the
trial started and very quickly they
settled it 787 and a half million
dollars we also talked about the last
minute strategy wherein Fox lawyers were
trying to introduce evidence essentially
blaming Donald Trump for the claims that
were made on air okay we have now gotten
beyond that it has been settled and in
writing Fox News did walk back the
claims that they made however we have
also learned for those of us waiting to
see Sean Hannity grovel and apologize or
Tucker Carlson say we were wrong they
are not going to have to do that part of
the settlement is that Fox News will not
have to apologize on air are for
broadcasting false claims about Dominion
Business Insider has a very uh precise
write-up about this Dominion voting
system settled its major defamation
lawsuit on Tuesday Fox agreed to pay
Dominion 787.5 million and acknowledged
that the false claims were broadcast Fox
News hosts will not be required to issue
apologies or retractions on air per a
source speaking to Insider this is part
of the negotiation which I'm sure was of
critical importance to Fox News now I
know that many of you will say
what is the reason that Dominion would
accept this if that is not going to be
part of the settlement why wouldn't
Dominion insist that there have to be
on-air apologies versus uh allowing Fox
News out of that why wouldn't they say
we're not settling we're going to trial
if you're not going to admit on air and
the reason is very simple and I spoke to
a couple of trial attorneys civil
attorneys about this over the last 24
hours imagine that you're Dominion and
you bring a 1.6 billion dollar lawsuit
against Fox News and a whole bunch of
time and resources and money have been
spent just even getting to trial and
you're presented with two options option
number one is you go through a four to
six week trial you might be confident
that you'll get a verdict in your favor
with a nice settlement but you don't
know that for sure and even if you do
you then have to collect it and there
can be appeals and there can be delays
and there can be all sorts of different
things this could take years
and then you get to collect whatever
you're able to get in a trial or
Fox News just gives you half of what you
ask for and you probably were already
inflating what you asked for at the
beginning knowing that the settlement
might end up being less but but but Fox
won't have to apologize on air
the answer is it depends how ego driven
this is if Dominion is primarily
concerned with the sort of punitive and
humiliating nature of getting Hannity to
apologize on air
then it would make sense to say no that
can't be part of the settlement or we're
going to trial or whatever but my guess
is and it doesn't sound like a crazy
decision to make my guess is Dominion
lawyers said listen
this is a sure bet of nearly 800 million
and we wrap it up quickly and we move
into collecting the 800 million but
they're not going to apologize on air
they will apologize in writing and at
least as far as your future business
with States the apology in writing is
probably pretty good why not just take
the 800 million and get the hell out of
here rather than going forward for weeks
and what could become months or years
before you actually collect I get it I
get it now as a public person who just
has an opinion as to the destructive and
corrosive nature of what Fox News did
around the election on air obviously I
would love to get it's sort of like the
perp walk of sorts right I would love to
see Hannity even if it's a short and
andersely worded apology of some kind
have to make a statement on air I would
enjoy that it would be great it would be
great for the lulls as the kids like to
say these days but I understand why
Dominion wouldn't hold out for that so
for those those of you who are saying
well we're now going to get that apology
the apology came in writing a fox and
the article mentions this a fox
spokesperson said an email
we acknowledge the Court's rulings
finding certain claims about Dominion to
be false this settlement reflects Fox's
continued commitment to the highest
journalistic standards that's hilarious
we are hopeful that our decision to
resolve this dispute with Dominion
amicably instead of the acrimony of a
divisive trial allows the country to
move forward from these issues so listen
I would have liked to see the apology
we're not going to get it and I
completely understand why Dominion is
not insisting on that Joe Biden and Jill
Biden have released their 2022 taxes and
even though right-wingers are trying to
make a controversy out of them I have to
tell you there is nothing controversial
about the Biden income nor the Biden
taxes but David they made more than half
a million dollars
let's go through it the the bidens did
indeed make
579 thousand dollars last year as a
household and they paid a 23.8 percent
federal tax rate plus of course state
tax as well now there are people seeing
this and saying oh my goodness this is
just like trump super wealthy
multi-millionaires no guys no without
passing any value judgment over income
it's very important to understand that
Trump made like 400 million dollars a
year during his presidency above was
about 1.6 billion throughout the the
entire presidency if I recall correctly
um and is a multi-billionaire at least
as far as We Know Joe Biden is a
multi-millionaire that's true so is
Bernie Sanders I've explained before if
you've been making six figures for 30
years you should be a multi-millionaire
by the time you're 80. even if you save
only a modest amount of your income and
put it in uh low-cost index funds and
wait for 30 years if you're not a
multi-millionaire you've messed up
you're really bad with money that's not
controversial now 579 thousand dollar
combined income presidents make 400
Grand a year is it 400 or 440 is it's a
it's around four hundred thousand
dollars a year that's the presidential
salary that's the vast majority of their
income Jill Biden also made uh what was
it here about eighty thousand dollars uh
teaching and they ended up yeah 82 000
teaching at Northern Virginia Community
College totally standard uncontroversial
salary so that gets us to 482 thousand
dollars and then there was a little bit
of income I don't remember
um what it was for
um they made some donations uh to some
Charities and blah blah blah blah blah
so what is the right saying about this
the best they have is Joe Biden is using
an S corporation for his book profits
this is the best they have and in fact
there's a Fox News article
um they've they've gone at this before
this is a couple years old
multi-millionaire Biden's use of s
corporations draws scrutiny by
Republican who sees hypocrisy I even got
emails from some in my audience who said
that there are people on the left
criticizing Biden for using an S
corporation for his book I listen guys
I'm calling this stuff like it is there
is nothing controversial about Joe Biden
running his book profits through an S
corporation I got emails about this
being shady
and just like Donald Trump give me a
break okay only if you know nothing
about taxes could you come to the
conclusion that simply having an S
corporation is in any way sketchy first
of all
authors don't set up
a C Corp
for a book you just don't do it if they
did then you have to pay yourself via
salary and dividends it just doesn't
make any sense if you're a small
business like the author of a book and
you want to separate those
um uh revenues from just yourself as an
individual sole proprietorship the S
corporation or a partnership might might
make perfect sense there's nothing
illegal there's nothing Shady it's a
standard practice it's passed through
income it goes on your personal tax
return it's not evasive it's not a
loophole it's a completely standard way
that small businesses that don't want to
just be sole proprietorships would set
up Revenue in this case you get some
liability protection you also I mean
listen if you have a full-time job in
the case of Joe Biden Senator vice
president president it's very logical
that if you have a defined and distinct
project like a book
that you would separate that and not run
it as a sole proprietorship through your
social security number you would get an
EIN and set it up as an S corporation it
lets you pay yourself a reasonable
salary take the remainder as
distributions you can potentially reduce
your tax liability slightly because it
can potentially reduce self-employment
taxes but Joe Biden's maxing out on that
anyway because he makes 400 Grand a year
and the cap is in the mid 150s this is
like milk toast milk toast stuff and
whether you're on the left or the right
and you're saying Biden's just like
Trump because his book profits run
through an S corporation you're either
arguing in bad faith or you just don't
understand even the basics about small
business taxes so I I don't think we
need to entertain it any further
579k in income when you're the president
and your wife works that makes a lot of
sense paid we can say well the tax at
that level of income should be higher
fine but an effective tax rate federally
of 24 and then paying Delaware attacks
totally reasonable totally expected I
think that's a higher tax rate than
Warren Buffett pays by the way even
though the Biden's made a lot less
there's nothing controversial here Biden
paid his taxes he released his tax
returns if we could only say the same
thing for Donald Trump
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show today I'm
going to talk about the hypocrisy of
Republicans when it comes to business
Freedom that they claim to espouse and
low regulations which they claim to
support and this is all kind of coming
on the heels of yesterday's Ron DeSantis
Disney World I'll build a prison next to
Disney threat and controversy which is
really just one of dozens and dozens of
data points of Republicans who claim to
be about business freedom and low
regular relation
immediately abandoning that principle to
the extent that it's even a principle as
soon as it's politically inconvenient
now in order to understand where this
hypocrisy comes from and why it's so
glaring today you really have to
understand the history of the Republican
party as for decades and decades and
decades claiming to be the party of
business freedom of low regulations of
economic freedom and uh pro-business and
all of these things they said for
decades excessive regulation is a burden
on businesses and it hurts profits and
it stifles economic growth and therefore
it prevents hiring and the best thing we
can do for workers and for the economy
and for investors for everybody
is to keep regulations low and stay out
of the way of businesses let the market
decide which businesses succeed and
which businesses fail the truth is so
much more pathetic it's we support
business freedom in theory when it suits
our interests and doesn't conflict with
personal vendettas grievances or other
inconvenient realities now let's take a
look at some examples and again
understand that there was a period even
if you disagree with this uh obsessive
focus on unburdening businesses or
regulations you might disagree with that
we can still acknowledge that at a
certain point
conservatives as they once were
were actually much more committed to
that I would still disagree with them in
many cases and say no we need regulation
but there was a point at which when they
said it they meant it that's not the
case anymore Twitter Twitter is a recent
example that's a glaring one when it
comes to Twitter
many of these right-wingers immediately
abandoned their stated principles of
getting rid of burdensome regulations
and separating government from what
private companies do and said no Twitter
should be forced to publish my coveted
disinformation Twitter should be forced
to publish Hunter Biden nude pics which
violate their own terms of service
Twitter should be forced to let
governments decide or the government
decide what hateful ideology ideology or
hateful speech should be published
rather than saying let Twitter figure
out what it wants to do let Twitter
figure out what's good or bad for
business let Twitter make its decisions
assuming they're not illegal and let the
market of ideas and the marketplace of
people decide oh I don't like what
Twitter is doing so I'm not going to be
on Twitter anymore
that's the way that they claim they
operate but as Twitter showed us that's
not actually the way they operate when
they want to force their disinformation
onto a private platform Twitter
Republicans at one point pushed a law
that would have prevented States from
enacting their own regulations on
certain products they would argue oh you
know we need to protect businesses from
a patchwork of different regulations
from state to state it's burdensome to
business to say well we're going to
regulate your product this way in
Delaware but in New York it's going to
be different and then in Florida it's
going to be different so they pushed a
law that said you can't do that you
can't just let states regulate products
differently in each state but when it
comes to environmental regulations
Republicans don't care about a patchwork
of regulations they want to strip the
epa's federal power for example to
regulate greenhouse gas emissions at the
federal level and listen there are
states that aren't worried about that we
know let if a state isn't concerned if
you have a state like Montana for
example Jared Diamond has written about
this a lot if Montana wants to let the
uh you know the the soil and the land
and every water be ravaged by pollution
or Wyoming or let them do it you can't
have this oppressive EPA come in and
tell every state what they have to do
well that's the principle that you are
now going against you're against the
patchwork of laws but now you're okay
with the patchwork of laws if it might
prevent the regulation of greenhouse
gases they're willing to do it 50
different ways in each of the 50 states
because they want to make it difficult
to regulate greenhouse gas emissions
then we've got subsidies and this is you
know each one of these things I'm
mentioning is a category unto itself
with many examples we could go into but
let's now talk about subsidies the right
claims to be against government
intervention in the economy
picking winners and losers
Etc but they have no problem handing out
billions of dollars in subsidies to
certain industries including oil and
others when they are politically
convenient businesses when it comes to
labor regulations Republicans suddenly
are big fans of government intervention
they love the idea of how can we
interfere with business
to prevent workers from organizing and
forming unions for example they support
laws that make it more difficult for
workers to sue employers when there are
workplace violations you know if you
don't want to regulate the businesses
because you claim oh they have a they
have an incentive to regulate themselves
and if they put out a dangerous product
they'll get sued and they'll lose market
share and if they don't have good
working conditions for their employees
their employees will sue or quit well
but then they also want to make it more
difficult for the employees to sue
because it's in their interests the
truth as many of you have long suspected
is that Republicans only care about
business freedom and unburdening from
burdensome regulations when it serves
their interests when it comes to
protecting the environment or protecting
workers suddenly regulations are a
burden that need to be left did this uh
or or you need to put in a regulation
you need to put in a regulation that
prevents others from putting in
regulations it's whatever is convenient
at the time and this at the end of the
day is bad for the economy
it's bad for the sort of average health
of people as they are affected by the
lack of Regulation or a very oppressive
type of Regulation depending on who it
is that benefits and who is hurt the
well-being of workers the environment I
mean you all know it so we're going to
be going through over the next several
weeks each of these stated principles
unburden ourselves from regulation
except when you want to force your will
onto corporations we're going to look at
each of these and there are so many of
these stated principles that they claim
but don't actually follow this is the
first one business Freedom low
regulation we'll get to others over the
next few weeks all right let's shift
gears a little bit and talk about
something else many of you have written
to me and said David
I came in with a uh sort of open mind
and said I want to figure out on policy
do I agree more with Democrats or
Republicans great approach I think that
that's a worthy thing to do but then
many of you who write to me say
it doesn't really seem like Republicans
talk about policy anymore
like yeah if you look at a campaign
website you'll see a policy section for
a Republican and it'll include a lot of
buzzwords and seemingly kind of like
focus group paragraphs that don't really
say very much but when it comes to the
campaigns that they run
Republicans don't really seem to talk
about policy anymore and that's exactly
what I want to talk about today I want
to talk about how the Republican Party
has completely abandoned policy
it started before the Trump era but
acutely since the Trump era to the point
where now instead of actually talking
about issues that affect Americans lives
the Republican party has become focused
on grievances fear-based politics based
on lies about what Democrats or
immigrants or others will do and a
Resurgence in extremist social views
focused primarily on abortion and
anti-trans recently now let's start with
a recent example
after the 2020 election Republicans
refused to accept the results of the
election claiming that there was
widespread fraud they failed to win the
hearts and minds of the voters based on
policy and when they lost instead of
saying hey we're going to put forward a
policy set of ideas of pillars that will
be helpful to us in 2022 they spent two
years and now it's been more than two
years claiming that that election
actually was rigged that it was won by
Donald Trump and not by Joe Biden and
despite multiple
court rulings and recounts audits they
continue to Peddle that lie and it is a
way that they make voters afraid they
make voters afraid and angry which are
the main emotions at this point that are
being utilized by Republicans to try to
convince people to come to their side
and that is at the core
of so much of the rhetoric that comes
from the modern Republican party another
example is the focus on extremist social
views Republicans have now become
fixated on pushing anti-transgender
legislation in multiple States hundreds
of bills arguing we need to protect
women's sports and we need to protect
kids in bathrooms and we need to protect
the Integrity of uh but I don't know of
we can't have drag shows because if it's
bad and they're obsessed with that stuff
all of it is based on false premises
like trans people are pedophiles or
sexual predators there aren't already
laws to protect against harassment in
bathrooms when in fact they are the
reality that the concern even around
Sports is a slice of a slice of a slice
of a slice of all that is going on
within Sports and it's all about making
people afraid and angry that people like
for example trans women who they say say
are really men are going to take they're
either going to take your child's
innocence or take your child's Sports
trophy or whatever the case may be fear
anger that's the person who I should be
angry at on immigration it's the fear of
supposedly lazy brown people leeching
off of social welfare programs but also
taking all of our jobs and that's always
a funny one these insanely lazy people
who are willing to abandon their
families and everything they know risk
arrest and death to come to the United
States
are then going to come here and work in
jobs that you would actually be working
oh that's very confusing but it doesn't
matter it's about the fear as Tucker
Carlson has said of people coming into
the country from Central and South
America making the country dirtier and
poorer and taking jobs and being on
social welfare and whatever the case may
be it's an insane uh juxtaposition lazy
welfare recipients who take our jobs but
it is about making you afraid and angry
at those people rather than at the very
corporations that have lobbied against
regulations which would actually punish
them more severely if they hire
undocumented immigrants and on and on
and on Republicans have also been
obsessed with cancel culture and
perceived threats to free speech and
again it's all about fear and anger
they're going to take away your ability
to even speak at a school board meeting
are they
or are they going to ask me to stop when
I've ranted for 12 minutes about masks
and I'm not letting anybody else speak
well it is true I've said before
sometimes there can be an overreaction
to someone's speech but for the most
part the issue of cancel culture has
been blown completely out of proportion
by the Republican party to distract from
important policy discussions I'm not
going to redo my segment on do the
victims of cancel culture actually end
up canceled the answer is no I've
already talked about that but the reason
for the focus on all of these fear and
anger-based elements is really easy that
there you know sometimes there's
questions in politics which have very
difficult answers
the answer for why Republicans have
abandoned policy is because Republicans
are losing most policy battles when it
comes to the American public the
American public is as against most of
what were the Republican policies today
than they have been for a period of
decades and decades and decades there's
so many examples of this a majority of
Americans support measures like
Universal background checks for any gun
purchase even in between private people
gun show whatever the case may be
most Americans support raising the
minimum wage most Americans support
addressing climate change exactly how
differs but most Americans support doing
something about climate change most
Americans support abortion being legal
in most cases most Americans now support
gay marriage most Americans support
using taxes on the very rich to reduce
income inequality
those are all positions espoused only by
democrats for the most part with a few
exceptions in the Republican party so
when you look at that and you realize
well Republicans are opposed to all of
that or at least they were when they
used to talk about policy all they can
do is focus on grievances fear and anger
and that brings me to the last part of
this which is populist rhetoric I've
explained to you before that populist
rhetoric is not a set of policy ideas
it's not like oh populism means a higher
minimum wage well it might or it might
mean keeping brown people out of the
country right populist rhetoric is often
used to pull people in and then you dump
the policy on them and the policy can
differ dramatically the populist
rhetoric is a tool that politicians use
to Rally supporters and usually there is
some bad actor right is the bad actor
corporations or is the bad actor antifa
well I don't know it depends you know
what because sort of Point you're trying
to make and populist rhetoric can be
used to pull people into your movement
without actually talking about policy
the Republican Party
has been particularly Adept at using
populist rhetoric to appeal to its base
and much of that populist rhetoric uses
sphere and anger rather than actual
proposed policy Solutions and so the
totality of this is that we've seen a
dangerous shift away from any
substantive policy from Republicans and
instead towards increasingly extremist
views on social issues and uh focus on
Grievances and a focus on fear-based
politics and scapegoating and at the
core it is driven by the fact that they
have lost the country on average can you
find anti-gay marriage people of course
you can can you find anti-abortion
people absolutely there's a ton of them
but at the top level it's a country that
has continued to move to the left
economically and socially Republicans
have lost that and instead of saying
maybe we'll revisit our policies maybe
we'll change no we will use popular list
rhetoric to make people afraid and angry
we won't talk about policy and when we
lose we'll claim we won and try to steal
the election anyway
extraordinarily dangerous but it's where
we are now as we approach mid-2023
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
in his latest orange rant the failed
former and wannabe future president
Donald Trump is promising mandatory
homeless camps he looks completely
disoriented he looks swollen as usual
his right eye almost completely shut but
he says that he will ban homelessness
hey who knew homelessness had such a
simple solution just ban it by the way
ban the virus while you're at it let's
get rid of everything and he says that
there will be tent camps for the
homeless outside of cities this is so
deranged we heard him talk about it at
rallies but it is now being put out as
an actual idea of of policy if you can
call it policy for Trump's 2024 run
let's take a look at this then I'm going
to talk to you about the ugly dystopian
history of camps for people ban Urban
camp
possible
treatment
and services if they're willing to be
rehabilitated many of them don't want
that
we'll give them the option we will then
open up large Parcels of inexpensive
land bring in doctors psychiatrists
social workers and drug rehab
Specialists and create 10 cities where
the homeless can be relocated and their
problems identified
but we'll open up our cities again make
them livable and make them beautiful to
ban Urban care so listen pretending to
take this seriously for a second
I'm not big on tent cities and there's a
lot of historical precedent for these
sorts of camps being some of the ugliest
things that societies do I mean not only
is it inhumane and violates basic human
rights it also doesn't work and I always
think it's important when we talk about
these things to talk to those who might
support such a policy not only
ideologically but also pragmatically so
the first problem is that banning
homelessness in this way it assumes that
homelessness is a choice or a behavior
that you can eliminate with the right
punishment and that's a flawed
assumption at its core it ignores that
homelessness has so many complex factors
that causes it poverty is of course part
of it it's simple to say well poor
homeless people are poor poor people are
more likely to become homeless yes
that's absolutely true mental illness is
a component addiction is a component
lack of affordable housing in cities is
a component lack of effective public
transportation that can link lower
income residential areas with areas
where the jobs are is a factor I could
go on there's so many different factors
but what it should the takeaway should
be is
if you just criminalize homelessness it
doesn't really solve anything so when
you try to ban homelessness and you try
to force homeless people to live in a
tent camp outside of a city where I
guess they would be bussed to it once
you're there there's no jobs you're in
the middle of nowhere and and there's a
tent camp and that's it you're doing
nothing to address the underlying
conditions that got people to be
homeless in the first place but what you
do is you further marginalize them you
stigmatize the homeless population
because you're actually separating them
and saying oh if you're homeless you're
being brought out there
to the camp where you have no shot at
getting a job I mean forget about it
um and you actually perpetuate the
problem and make it even worse now if
you want to look at some historical
examples of this type of approach to
homelessness there are many historical
failures in the 20th century many
countries implemented mandatory
institutionalization programs for
homeless people and the idea is we're
going to provide shelter and treatment
which is arguably a good a nice thing
right I mean when Trump says we're going
to get people things that they need
we'll get them sheltered we'll get them
food we'll get them treatment at least
on an interim basis once we've
completely separated them from society
we know from the 20th century examples
that they end up being overcrowded
unsanitary
abusive very little effective treatment
provided
stigmatizing and alienating and
segregating so it doesn't actually
accomplish anything and what you end up
with is with many of these homeless
folks essentially trapped in these
places for years with conditions they
may have worsening
chances of reintegrating into society
dramatically decreasing and meanwhile
the homeless population continues to
swell another example of this
is looking specifically at tent cities
to house homeless populations in the
early 2000s there were cities in the
Pacific Northwest that established some
tent cities for homeless people and the
idea is temporary shelter temporary
shelter and exactly what I just
described to you is is what took place
they became overcrowded they became
unsanitary they weren't even properly
funded there was limited access to basic
amenities running water was scarce
sanitation facilities were leaving much
to be desired and they actually became
hot spots for crime and drug abuse which
only made the problem worse marginalized
people stigmatize them and you're not
making it more likely that they will be
what Republicans like to describe as
productive members of society so instead
of punishing with further marginalizing
programs for a population that's already
vulnerable we should instead be working
towards what causes the homelessness
imagine you say hey look all these
homeless people
let's not even think about what made
them homeless let's just ship them off
in bus buses to the desert and have them
live in tents indefinitely until what
until what happens so poverty lack of
affordable housing lack of support for
people
in their communities rather than by
separating them these are the types of
things that will help people reintegrate
into society and many of these programs
that are proposed and often underfunded
they're actually quite Revenue neutral
because yes they cost money but if you
care mostly about the finances they
eventually generate government revenue
by getting some fraction of those people
back to work paying taxes spending money
in the community so there's even a
fiscal conservatism argument to be made
swollen Trump though
I don't think he's ready to have this
conversation I am not going to do a full
segment on part two of the Elon Musk
Tucker Carlson interview yesterday we
looked at part one and we looked at a
bunch of it there are two clips that I
am compelled to play for you though
oh this was a sec this is so weird Elon
and Tucker
talked about
the urge to impregnate women
as the interview really took a strange
turn listen to this I mean the urge to
have sex and to procreate is after
breathing and eating the most basic urge
how has it been subverted
well it's just the in the past we could
rely upon
um you know simple uh limbic system
rewards in order to procreate um but
once you have birth control
um and you know uh abortions and whatnot
now now you now you can still satisfied
Olympic Instinct but not procreate
um so we didn't we haven't yet evolved
to
deal with that because this is all
fairly recent in the last 50 years or so
um for birth control you know I'm so
worried that hey civilization you know
if we don't make enough people to at
least sustain our numbers perhaps
increase a little bit then civilization
is going to crumble
this is actually I mean this is like
wacky stuff and you can tell from the
look on Tucker Carlson's face that it's
not even clear he really knows the
direction this is going there's a couple
interesting things here because on the
one hand what Elon Musk is saying is
quite reminiscent of extreme right-wing
strict father morality ideology when it
comes to birth control and one of the
things that some on the right don't like
about birth control you know you you do
hear some of them say Well it kind of
goes against the Bible you're not
supposed to it's
I I don't even know which parts of
scripture but there's some religious
claims that birth control violates the
Bible but for a lot of these right
Wingers and again I don't think Elon
Musk is a right winger on so many
different issues but he's delving here
into a view that is very very prominent
on the right wing the opposition to
birth control
isn't so much religious it's that you
shouldn't be able to engage in what they
call non-procreative sex and not have
consequences you should suffer the
strict father that's why we call the
strict father morality would say if
you're going to engage in sexual
intercourse there should be the
consequences of a pregnancy and if there
is you should be forced to carry the
baby to the the baby to turn
so he's kind of falling into that like
it's it's dangerous that we've separated
the limbic response from the procreation
and now we have a low birth rate he's
kind of toying with that same stuff and
then there's the low birth rate thing
which has become a focus for for Elon
Musk a question of like uh will
civilization end with a bang or a
whimper well it's currently trying to
end with a whimper in adult diapers yes
uh which is depressing as hell the most
depressing I mean seriously yeah war is
less depressing yeah it's really gone
with a bang yep your shoes on yeah not
with your more exciting there you go so
Tucker Carlson visibly sucking up to
Elon Musk throughout the entire
interview all right they did also talk
about
um uh the topic of aliens which was an
interesting moment yeah
um a lot of people ask me you know
um where are the aliens and I I think if
if anyone would know about aliens on
Earth it would probably be me I would
think yeah I'm like you know very
familiar with space stuff yeah
um
and I've seen no evidence of aliens
so there you go I would immediately
tweet you know tweet it out it says
Split Second they'll be like I'll be
like old time
probably a tough tweet of all time that
one guys
that's a jackpot 8 billion likes you
know
um Next Level jackpot if you find it
there you go so big reward on Twitter
for whoever announces proof of aliens
and every every aspect of this interview
very very strange and this will
certainly help to endear Elon Musk
further with the right wing Community
given the heroes welcome by Tucker
Carlson let's call this long two night
nightmare of the Elon Tucker interview
over and we can move on from there we
have a voicemail number 2192 David P
here's someone who says it was wrong for
me to go to England last week
um because there are there are poor
people uh this is this is tough listen
to this
so in the recent email
I demonstrated
my disappointment slash anger slash
something else
about the fact that you
went to England yep
I don't have an issue with England
I just have an issue with
how do you actually relate to the poor
people do you actually think I or the
people that you supposedly care about
can afford to go to England
or France or Spain or all these places
which are
Out Of Reach for many people
so the point of being angry was
you know
couldn't you maybe subtract one of those
trips and maybe donate it to a
charity that
actually helps the people that you claim
to care about which I'm sure you care
about but it's not very well
demonstrated but the fact that you know
uh since I've been following you you've
gone to I don't know maybe three or four
or five or six trips that are pretty
expensive
so listen anyway
um I it's just like
should I
who who gets to go on trips okay I
shouldn't go on any trips that not
everybody can afford
I should donate all my money to charity
what about a lawyer who says hey I care
about poor people so I'm going to do
some pro bono work but sometimes I'll go
to London with my family
if that lawyer really cared about the
poor people he does pro bono work for
he can't go to England either I mean
this is this is really just kind of a
weird path to go down
and
um you know I know that there are some
people in my audience who are going to
write to me and say David you don't have
to justify anything to that guy you you
do what you want to do you do the show
you want to do if people find that you
are not aligned because you went to
England with thinking everybody should
have health care then they can choose
not to listen but it's just
what are we doing guys what are we doing
and what what trips would be acceptable
right I mean should I go to uh uh should
I go to
should I go to uh Hudson New York
instead of England as the place I go
because it's more accessible I don't
know I don't know but at least this
person thinks I did something very very
wrong all right we have a great bonus
show for you today Mike Pompeo says he
won't run in 2024. Joe Biden has signed
an executive order to improve access to
child care and the South Dakota Governor
Christie Christie gnome Christy gnome
says that her two-year-old grandchild
has several guns what the hell is going
on in South Dakota and by the way I may
soon be going to South Dakota speaking
of trips I'll talk about this on the
bonus show today don't miss it sign up
at joinpakman.com
foreign